me I'm horrible at math like horrible so
how do you know I'm I'm thinking like
I'm like oh God I could not teach my
children math I
can't so how does that work if you're
not good at a subject or maybe School
wasn't really your thing how how does
that work whether or not The Homeschool
parents had any teaching certification
or any experienc teaching the outcomes
were roughly the same and the wonderful
thing nowadays is that we have a ton of
choices on curriculum on my channel my
next show is going to be about
homeschooling curriculum and how to
choose it and I have a really cool
publisher that I want to talk about who
makes um homeschooling materials that
are from before the era of modern public
education they're like the classical
classical learning style those are
really easy to follow along with they
have teaching guides um so basically
like I always tell people I probably
learned more homeschooling my kids
really than I taught yeah oh yeah